Donald Trump has been indicted well that
is the news on the street coming from
Donald Trump actually and while we don't
have all the information it looks like
the coming indictment is not over what
most people thought it looks like
Manhattan district attorney Alvin Bragg
will indict Donald Trump for the crime
of falsifying business records what
business record you say well the
business record showing payments to
adult film actress Stormy Daniels
Trump's former lawyer Michael Cohen went
to prison for among other things
facilitating a keep quiet payment to
Daniels on Trump's behalf and while the
facts are simple the law is not
falsifying business records is generally
a misdemeanor to make a felony New York
prosecutors would have to show that
Trump had actual intent to commit
another crime the prosecutor might argue
that the hush money payments was
intended to violate campaign Finance
laws which is all the can of worms so
how did we get here now in case you were
in a Rip Van Winkle style coma and have
just woken up hold on to your wig
because I have some news in 2016 the
host of The Apprentice was the
Republican nominee for president on
October 7 2016 The Washington Post
published a video showing Donald Trump
and a member of the Bush family making
some lewd comments about women and while
Trump was battling the so-called Access
Hollywood tape Stormy Daniels a prolific
Entertainer in adult films threatened to
go public after her alleged affair with
Trump Michael Cohen who was then Trump's
personal quote attorney slash fixer
facilitated hush money payments to
Daniels the payments were meant to keep
Daniels quiet so that Trump would win
the election at least according to Cohen
now the Access Hollywood tape was
thought to be the death nail for Trump's
campaign and it caused many politicians
to back away from Trump without really
backing away from him but despite the
rumors and the Access Hollywood tapes
Trump won the election now during that
frantic time however no one knew how the
tape would impact the campaign Trump and
his advisors had already anticipated
that women would go forward to the media
with claims about Trump and they came up
with a plan to deal with it in 2015
Trump and Cohen met up with David pecker
the chairman of American Media Inc the
company that publishes The National
Enquirer and other tabloids pecker
agreed to help Trump fend off claims
from all the women he definitely did not
have affairs with over the years and at
Pecker's Direction The National Enquirer
and other tabloids agreed to catch and
kill stories about Trump by negotiating
for the exclusive rights to the negative
stories about Trump and then never
publishing the stories they paid for now
six weeks before the Republican National
Convention former Playboy Bunny Karen
McDougall was set to go public about her
alleged affair with Trump in June of
2016 however Pecker's company purchased
the rights to mcdougall's life story for
150 000 pecker then assigned the rights
to Cohen for 125 thousand dollars Cohen
Incorporated a shell company called
resolution Consultants LLC to receive
the money now he secretly recorded a
conversation with Trump explaining the
arrangement I need to open up a company
for the transfer of all of that info
regarding our friend David you know so
that I'm going to do that right away
I've actually come up and when Cohen
told Trump that they have to come up
with some financing Trump suggested
paying by check or maybe even using cash
so I'm I'm all over that and I spoke to
Alan about it when it comes time for the
financing which will be listening
what happened
I got no no no obviously Cohen decided
to use a shell company here because
ostensibly he was a lawyer uh pecker
sent the paperwork to Cohen but then
backed out of the deal however pecker
kept his antenna up for other women who
were shopping stories about Trump in
October of 2016 pecker told Cohen that
porn star Stormy Daniels was willing to
sell her story and was already in talks
with Good Morning America Cohen
negotiated an agreement with Daniels to
purchase her silence for 130 000 and to
arrange a payment that was not linked
directly to Trump Cohen Drew Down 130
000 from his home equity line of credit
and requested that it be deposited into
the bank account of another shell
company essential Consultants Cohen then
wired 130 000 from essential Consultants
directly to daniels's lawyer now the
paperwork required for the wire transfer
indicated that the transaction's purpose
was a quote retainer Now spoiler now
that's not what a legal retainer is or
what it's for but after the transaction
was complete Daniel signed a
confidentiality agreement and side
letter agreement with Cohen everything
thing worked according to plan and in
2017 Cohen started invoicing the Trump
organization to recoup the money and the
payments were broken up after pay style
so that every month Cohen submitted an
invoice for 35 000 as stated quote
pursuant to the retainer agreement
kindly remit payment for services
rendered for the relevant month now
according to the justice department
quote in truth and in fact there was no
such retainer agreement and the monthly
invoices Cohen submitted were not in
connection with any legal service he had
provided in 2017. now the Trump
organization labeled the payments legal
expenses and by the end of 2017 the
payments to Cohen totaled 420 000 and
the payments were apparently grossed up
for tax purposes because otherwise Cohen
would have to pay tax on the income and
not be fully reimbursed for the payout
so Cohen billed 360 000 for the claims
and also got a sixty thousand dollar
bonus now what did Trump say about all
this well the usual he'd never have an
affair and if he did have one it
wouldn't be with Stormy Daniels
eventually Trump got around to admitting
that he worked with Cohen to pay Daniels
off but he said that there were quote no
campaign funds go going into this which
would have been a problem and in May of
2018 things went from bad to worse when
Rudy Giuliani got involved and confirmed
that the Daniels payment was funnel
through and the president repaid it and
as per usual Rudy stepped in big time
telling Hannity that Trump needed to pay
off Daniels to influence the election
quote imagine if that came out on
October 15 2016 in the middle of the you
know last debate with Hillary Clinton
Cohen didn't even ask Cohen made it go
away he did his job Rudy tried to
backtrack by saying that the main
concern wasn't the election it was the
allegations hurting Trump personally
quote it wasn't for the campaign it was
to save their not their marriage as much
as their reputation on May 3rd 2018
Trump tweeted in a mission that he
repaid Cohen for the Daniel settlement
through a monthly retainer on August
22nd 2018 Trump said these payments
weren't a campaign Finance violation
because they quote came from me and I
tweeted about it of course what Trump is
leaving out here is that the 35 000
installment payments were definitely not
for legal word Cohen was performing for
him each month during the investigation
Trump organization CFO Alan weisselberg
and David pecker cooperated and were
granted immunity Cohen for his part
pleaded guilty to two campaign Finance
violations testifying the quote Donald
Trump directed him to commit a crime by
making payments to two women for their
principal purpose of influencing an
election Cohen's payment was considered
an in-kind contribution to the 2016
Trump campaign Cohen could only lawfully
give fifty four hundred dollars to
support Trump's candidacy at the time so
the 130 000 payoff violated the law
because it was too big now Cohen also
pleaded guilty to paying off Karen
McDougall which violated a federal law
called the Tillman act now the the
Tillman act borrows corporations from
spending in federal elections and Cohen
was sentenced to three years and
released early which brings us to Ami
now the campaign Finance law prevents
corporations from spending money to
influence elections in coordination with
the candidate or campaign prosecutors
said that Ami's payment to McDougall
amounted to a secret in-kind
contribution to Trump's campaign during
the election The National Enquirer ran
headlines about Hillary Clinton's sleazy
Affairs even accusing her of paying off
reporters to bury the truth but it never
ran a negative article about Trump am I
admitted to meeting with Trump back in
2015 to help him handle negative stories
that could have impacted the
presidential campaign uh the company
admitted negotiating with McDougall at
the direction of Michael Cohen it also
admitted paying 150 000 which was much
higher than the company's normal rates
because the company had Cohen's promise
that he would pay it back Amis deal with
McDougall was extraordinary in another
way uh pecker promised her that she
would get two magazine covers and that
the company would publish a hundred
articles written by McDougall Ami
entered into a non-prosecution agreement
with the doj to avoid liability for its
illegal role in this payment now you
could look at this deal as a doj giving
Ami a slap on the wrist the company
wasn't prosecuted or even fined even
though it admitted to violating the law
instead Ami was required to develop
compliance programs and pecker kept his
job but on the other hand the doj could
say that the non-prosecution agreement
was worth it since it gave the doj
enough ammo to prosecute and convict
Cohen but then what about Donald Trump
trump was not referred to in the
criminal information against Cohen but
he was memorably known as individual
number one Cohen has told everyone who
would listen including Congress and a
New York Grand jury that Trump was
personally involved in or briefed about
the Daniels agreement every step of the
way yet last fall I pled guilty in
federal court
to felonies for the benefit of
at the direction of
and in coordination with individual
number one
for the record
individual number one
president Donald J Trump so why wasn't
he prosecuted for violating the federal
election campaign Act well Cohen was
charged with violating FICA the law
limits donations by individuals and bans
corporations from making any
contributions to candidates hush money
payments are illegal contributions if
they are deemed to be in-kind
contributions to the campaign and
according to the FEC any expenditure
that a person or entity makes or
cooperation or consultation in concert
with or at the request or suggestion of
a candidate's campaign is also
considered an in-kind contribution to
the candidate the FEC also says that the
value of an in-kind contribution the
usual and normal charge counts against
the contribution limit as a gift of
money does and these contributions have
to be reported to the FEC Cohen's
payments to the two women went over the
donation limits and were not disclosed
and as a presidential candidate and as
president Trump was required to file
annual personal financial disclosure
reports that detailed various Financial
Holdings income sources and debts
Trump's 2017 Financial disclosure did
not disclose a debt to Cohen or a Cohen
related entity like the ones described
by Giuliani the McDougall payment was an
obvious violation law because the
corporation Ami paid money money to
McDougall and most campaign Finance
violations are treated as civil cases
but when someone admits to knowingly and
willfully violating the law the doj will
file criminal charges sometimes now the
doj could have charged trumpet at the
time his doj followed the Watergate era
doj memo about not indicting a sitting
president which of course is
controversial in its own right now we've
talked about this policy before and the
reasons why it's probably not correct
but every doj has followed it so far and
so why didn't the justice department
charge Trump after he left the White
House well sources said the prosecutors
were worried about the reliability of
Cohen as a witness particularly since he
was charged with lying to Congress about
a project Trump had going on in Russia
and the prosecutors also concluded that
new Witnesses were unlikely to come
forward so New York City district
attorney Alvin Bragg can't prosecute
Trump for federal campaign Finance
violations so how can local prosecutors
make a case out of the old Daniel's
payment will Bragg charge Trump with
falsifying business records by recording
Cohen's reimbursement for the Daniel's
payment as legal fees but that's only a
misdemeanor under New York law unless
prosecutor can prove that he falsified
records to conceal another crime New
York penal law section 175.10 makes it a
crime to delete alter or make a false
entry in the business records of an
Enterprise with the intent to defraud
this is a misdemeanor charge unless
prosecutors can prove intent to further
conceal another criminal offense the
maximum sentence for a misdemeanor
conviction is up to one year in jail
while the felony offense carries a
potential penalty of up to four years
now the statute of limitations is two
years for the misdemeanor and five years
for the felony now to get a conviction
for falsifying business records the
government has to prove the following
Beyond a reasonable doubt that someone
makes or causes a false entry in the
business records of an Enterprise or two
Alters a racist obliterates deletes
removes or destroys a true entry in the
business records of an Enterprise or
three amidst to making a true entry in
the business records of an Enterprise in
violation of a duty to do so which he
knows to be imposed upon Him by law or
by the nature of his position or four
prevents the making of a true entry or
causes the Omission thereof in the
business records of an Enterprise and
improve felony falsification the
government has to prove those elements
plus one more that the person's intent
to defraud includes an intent to commit
another crime or to Aid or conceal the
commission thereof now a defendant who
requests that someone else do the actual
work of recording a false business
record can be just as criminally liable
as if they did it themselves and there
could be other crimes that could lead to
a felony enhancement New York State
elections laws could be a predicate
defense for the record-keeping violation
even though the presidential contest was
a federal election article 14 of the New
York state election law and part 6200 of
the New York State Board of Elections
rules and regulations govern campaign
Finance these regulations govern
everything from the time and place to
file campaign disclosure reports to the
violations and penalties for failing to
abide and buy the rules for example New
York elections lost section
17-1752 which covers conspiracy to
promote or prevent an election says that
quote any two or more persons who
conspire to promote or prevent the
election of any person to a public
office by unlawful means in which
conspiracy is acted upon by one or more
of the parties thereto shall be guilty
of a misdemeanor and there are a number
of New York elections law that relate to
the expenditure of funds in furtherance
of one's campaign auditionally might be
related to a tax evasion crime since
theoretically he would have taken a
business deduction related to the
payments to Cohen so why is Alvin Bragg
acting now we don't know for sure but
maybe there's no evidence The Wall
Street Journal reported that in
September of 2016 Cohen refused to pay
off Daniels but he changed his mind in
October right after the Access Hollywood
tape was released if true this would
create an inference that the payments
were meant to influence the campaign
just like pecker and Cohen said in
addition New York Times reported that
the day before Cohen wired the 130 000
he spoke to Trump twice by phone on the
day after the payment Cohen and Trump
spoke again Giuliani said the campaign
did not want to have the Daniel's
bombshell drop during a debate with
Hillary Clinton the grand jury recently
heard testimony from Killian Conway and
we don't know what she said but as a key
advisor to his campaign maybe she
testified about whether the payment was
made with a debate in mind and remember
at the final debate Trump had set up a
stunt his guests were some of of the
women who accused Bill Clinton of
assault and sexual harassment so how
would it have looked if the Daniel's
bombshell had dropped before that debate
but it should be noted that there are
also some serious statute of limitations
issues the New York statute of
limitations for most felonies including
the ones we've discussed is five years
for misdemeanors just two years and the
conducted issue here occurred largely in
2016 more than five years ago though
maybe there was some undisclosed conduct
that continued past 2016. one possible
exception is when the potential
defendant is continuously outside of the
state Trump rarely went to New York
during his presidency but this law is
mainly intended for criminals who leave
the state and hide not really the case
here there was also former Governor
Cuomo's executive order tolling the
statute of limitations for most crimes
because of the covet Emergency near
courts have ruled that the order told
these statue of limitations giving most
claims an additional 228 days but at the
moment it's unclear what Bragg might be
relying on for the statute limitations
issue now Trump has said this is not a
state case it is a federal case and they
have all passed on it and in some ways
Trump's assessment is correct the doj
prosecuted Cohen and penalized Ami for
conduct both parties did to help Trump
win the election that gave the
Department of Justice a prime
opportunity to prosecute him but the doj
passed in addition to arguing about the
statute of limitations Trump has other
good defenses to the felony prosecution
first of all it's not clear that the
prosecutor can use a violation of
federal law as the basis for the felony
enhancement a court could rule that
falsifying business records is only a
felony if it quote aided or concealed a
New York State Crime not a federal one
there could be other federal crimes
implicated by Trump's conduct like wire
fraud but again this is a federal crime
and some lawyers in the DA's office have
reportedly thought that they could not
charge Trump with falsifying a business
record to commit a federal crime now the
statute also says quote a person is
guilty of falsifying business records in
the first degree when his intent to
defraud includes an intent to commit
another crime or Aid or conceal the
commission thereof so does the phrase
another crime mean that it can be any
crime state or federal we don't have a
definitive answer and the statute is
unclear and there's no case law
interpreting the phrase another crime
Bragg can certainly argue that there
have been in many similar prosecutions
for falsifying business records to cover
up a federal crime as reported Trump's
CFO Alan weisselberg was just convicted
of a state felony based on false entries
made in federal tax forms if a judge
agrees that the federal campaign
violation is viable then Trump will then
defend himself on the basis that he did
not have the intent to violate the law
his argument here could be decent his
own tweets show that doesn't really
understand campaign Finance law he's
shown confusion about whether it's legal
for him to use his personal funds to
reimburse a loan from Cohen to the
campaign for instance and in Cohen's
case the doj asserted that contributions
and expenditures under FICA include just
about anything that could influence a
campaign but is paying off a mistress
truly a campaign expense that is
designed to influence a campaign fika is
a complicated law with lots of nuance on
how it's interpreted and Trump doesn't
exactly seem like a guy that grasps the
Nuance of these kinds of laws and Trump
has already raised the advice of council
defense to prove that defense under New
York law Trump would have to show that
Cohen told him that Daniel's payments
were legal and that he rely ion Cohen's
advice in good faith that's not exactly
a defense so much as a way to show he
doesn't have the requisite intent under
the law and this could set up a he said
he said problem for the jury will they
believe Cohen a prosecuted liar or a
trump just an extremely well-known liar
and Trump can attack the prosecutor's
claim that he misrepresented the
payments to Cohen quote with the intent
to defraud or instructed someone else to
do it for him the federal prosecution of
Cohen didn't come to that conclusion in
the coincidencing memorandum the doj
said that Cohen submitted bogus invoices
quote at the instruction of an executive
for the company was that executive
Donald Trump or someone else maybe Alan
weiselberg this sets up a classic it
wasn't me defense for Trump which is
something that he's wielded well over
the years and it might seem unfair for
Cohen to serve time for something he did
at Trump's Direction but that's
sometimes what happens when you have a
slam dunk case against subordinate and
you have all of these intents and other
motive related questions for the people
that are higher up of course if Trump is
arrested he'll want a nice home cooked
meal before he goes to jail and the best
way to do that is with today's sponsor
hellofresh hellofresh is a great way to
eat delicious fresh food while still
being healthy it's a great way to get
back into a diet or just eat great food
in fact hellofresh has a whole variety
of calorie smart carb smart pescaderian
and veggie options so you can customize
it how you like hellofresh delivers
fresh quality produce from the farm to
your door in less than a week so you can
enjoy favorites like soy glazed salmon
with rice or mushroom and chive risotto
I usually go with the high protein
options like one pot pork and black bean
chili or creamy Dijon dill chicken now
I'm a do-it-yourself person and I have
to say I was initially pretty skeptical
at hellofresh I'm a pretty good cook so
I didn't think that I needed the help
but I actually loved it even for an
experienced cook hellofresh delivers new
ingredients and recipes that I'd never
try on my own and of course everything
was delivered straight to my door so I
didn't have to do any of the shopping
the produce actually gets to you faster
than a grocery store so it arrives at
Peak freshness and flavor and it's also
super easy to save time hellofresh cuts
out the meal planning and prep so the
recipes take only 20 to 30 minutes to
cook literally less time to cook than it
would normally take to do the shopping
and it's also incredibly sustainable
since the ingredients are pre-portioned
there's less prep and less wasted food
and the packaging is almost entirely
made from recyclable or already recycled
content and hellofresh's carbon
footprint is actually 25 lower than that
of meals made from store-bought
groceries and 72 cheaper than dining at
a restaurant so if you'd like to try
hellofresh go to hellofresh.com and use
the code legallyagle60 for 60 off plus
free ship yes you can actually get 60
off plus free shipping by clicking on
the link that's on screen right now or
down in the description so click on the
link that's on screen right now and go
to hellofresh.com and use the code
legaleagle60 or just click on the link
below plus click on that link really
helps out this channel after that click
on this playlist over here for more
legal eagle or I'll see you in court